What a strange picture!
Do you know what these things are?
They are called snack machines, or vending machines.
What is your favorite snack when you're hungry?
Well, for about two dollars, you can choose something delicious from these machines.
Put in your money, and then watch your food drop to the bottom.
Sometimes people have to shake the machine if their snack gets stuck on the way down.
It's very frustrating to have your snack stuck in the machine when you're hungry.
There are candy, chocolate bars, chips, soda pop and even coffee.
These snacks are not very good for your body,...
...but they sure taste good.
Which snack would you choose?
My favorite treats are the chocolate bars.
When you eat too many chocolate bars,...
...you might get into trouble with your dentist.